so raven steelers on for tonight
i made the comment last night only half
jokingly in a post at pft that nothing
short of a full-blown zombie apocalypse
is going to keep this game from going
forward
that's just what it is like yesterday
when it was time for the ravens crop
report multiple reporters
claimed that there were no new positives
for the ravens which means someone
somewhere connected to the broader nfl
machinery was telling
reporters
no new positives for the ravens lo and
behold
one new player positive and one new
staff positive for the ravens hmm
peculiar that that would be the case
they still loaded up the plane they flew
to pittsburgh they're playing tonight
they're playing tonight they're playing
tonight they're going to do point of
care testing on site today i don't know
what that's going to mean if there are
more positives they're still going to
play this game nothing at this point
chris is going to stop them from playing
this game tonight i mean it doesn't seem
like it and i mean we've talked about it
the last few days to where
i get it it's uh
whoa you're opening up a can of worms if
you cancel this and it's a lot of other
issues that we've we've dove into
where i just go mike there is
i mean we've seen teams do this already
right i mean we saw new england who
there was the stephon gilmore still got
on a plane even though they knew he
might have been in close contact with
people there blah blah blah and then it
kind of went through the team i mean
it's just tremendously risky that's all
i can really say but hopefully between
you know that that bracelet or they're
the like forget the what the hell is the
name of that thing they say the contact
contracting tracing device exactly right
that you know hopefully they have enough
info from that to feel comfortable about
okay nobody was around these guys and
we'll see where it goes but it seems
like the nfl is willing to roll the dice
a little bit here with these type of
issues as long as it's just not totally
a full-blown
you know outbreak on a football team
the game has been delayed for so long
that the original two players who were
presumed to be unavailable for the
ravens are now available as of today
running backs mark ingram and jk dobbins
who tested
sunday of last week the overtime
loss loss loss it's been so long i can't
remember loss to the titans
they got knocked out the next day they
were part of the initial outbreak they
now are eligible to return today this is
a game that's been delayed by six days i
mean think about it week 12 began last
thursday
tonight and they do have
expect i'm assuming there's no further
positive for dobbins and ingram today
they'll be back tonight traveling
separately they won't have lamar jackson
at quarterback tonight rg3 instead and
rg3 started several games against
pittsburgh over the course of his career
he had time with the cleveland browns
last year week 17 he played against the
steelers in week 17 when the uh the the
ravens pulled guys like lamar jackson
but i still go back to 2012 when rg3 was
taking the league by storm and
washington played at pittsburgh and mike
tomlin company had a very simple
approach
hit him just hit him right hit him every
chance you get they ran him on a on a
pass route
trick play yeah at one point
he got clobbered down the field and ryan
clark was was very open about it i don't
know whether it was at the time or
after he was in that that that mode
where he was playing and working for
espn but at some point he came out and
said look that's what we did to him and
it worked so uh get ready for more of
that tonight the steeler is not bashful
about getting physical with quarterbacks
who choose to run and it's likely we'll
see rg3 run the ball and one of the
problems with him over the years chris
has been his inability and or
unwillingness to avoid contact he
welcomes it remember this first game for
the browns what'd he do dropped his
shoulder dropped his shoulder into an
eagles defensive back and he was out for
most of the season yeah had a chance to
kind of revive his career and get back
on track and decide to lower his
shoulder there you're right that was
that was big um
i mean you're right he's different than
lamar jackson lamar jackson just he's
special as far as a quarterback or
runner i've really never seen a guy like
that quick
that good of a runner who can run
through traffic and still has just a
great feel of you know never taking big
hits kind of getting down as he's
getting in the scrum of getting hit yeah
rg3 is not gifted like that he's a
little longer and more gangly not to be
disrespectful to where yeah he's he's
more of a straight liner and if he's got
somewhere to go and it's a straight line
watch out but he's not going to be you
know juking people out and making them
look silly and breaking ankles and doing
all that either way though the threat of
the run will still be there with rg3 and
i think that's the thing that
baltimore needs not that they need him
to rip off a hundred yard game rushing
but if they can just have a threat so
all right at the end of the night we
look up and we might see six rushes for
48 yards something like that then he's
done his job and the fact that this has
been delayed so long and now they got
these running backs back ingram dobbins
to go along with gus edwards man that's
that's a great gift for this football
team you know i don't know about you
mike i mean i know it's gonna be a weird
week tough week all of that i'm just i'm
still not counting baltimore out in this
one i just think it's desperation i
think they'll be pissed and i think uh
you might catch pittsburgh in a little
bit like what the hell is going on here
this week we're playing wednesday at 3
40 and i just have a feeling i'm just a
gut like you like you're good spaghetti
and meatballs
interesting contrast because shireen
williams on pftpm gives the ravens
absolutely no chance
chance that this is the equivalent of
the broncos having no quarterbacks on
sunday against the saints no chance to
win even though the ravens have
rg3 she thinks and i i tend to agree the
steelers are going to be salty the
stylers are going to be
pissed sorry london the steelers are
going to let out a full week of
frustration on the ravens and remember
last wednesday when the game was first
bumped from thanksgiving there was the
rash of complaints on social media from
steelers players yeah that all ended
quickly mike tomlin
i think took their phones and mike
tomlin made it clear to them we will not
complain we we will do our complaining
on the football field you don't like
what's happened you let them know about
it during the game now i'm not saying
that that's what they should do i'm just
saying that that's that's the football
coach that's what mike tomlin is he's
going to channel that aggression
toward the things that they do on the
football field hit the guy across from
you a little bit harder but legally play
a little more aggressively but legally
but if you're mad
use that direct that toward what you're
gonna be doing that's why i
i hear what you're saying the ravens are
desperate but i think what's happened to
the ravens over the past week you forget
about desperation you forget about the
you're just trying to get your paychecks
at this point you're just trying to make
sure everybody's healthy at this point
trying to get back to the postseason i
mean last year isn't going to happen
again 14 and 2 is not going to happen
again the best they can be is 12 and 4.
and they aren't going to beat 12 and 4
based on how they've played recently i
just think that it's survival mode more
than desperation mode for the ravens at
this point yeah it's interesting i mean
it's a psychology experiment really i i
don't know i'm just you know again first
off i'm playing a little bit on that too
of
the ravens physically had their way with
pittsburgh too the first time around you
know we know that and i bet you they'll
have a little bit of a different
approach on defense to where hey it's
going to throw big ben a curveball that
but you're right mike i don't know where
this goes i mean i don't know i just
would be shocked i mean we've seen teams
and i know we got the raiders at two
different games where they've dealt with
covid one they were successful and
played very close against kansas city
chiefs you know with the defensive line
not practicing all that week i know the
other time they got beat by the bucks
pretty handily without their offensive
line being able to practice but we saw
the tennessee titans not really have a
lot of time to prepare and still somehow
come out and whoop the crap out of the
the buffalo bills so
i i'm just saying i understand they're
missing players and it's been a
whirlwind of a week
but
meetings preparation
team that this far into the year i just
i don't think they're going to be like a
total slop fest tonight that's all i'm
saying i think it's going to be a good
competitive football game and i would i
would be shocked if the steelers blew
out the ravens i really would be shocked
i just believe that the ravens have been
through a roller coaster ride over the
last week and a half that no one else
has dealt with short of the titans but
you know what when the titans went
through it what did they do what did
they do they they actually seem to play
better maybe i know that's what i'm
saying
becomes the football field and now now
the difference is and ryan tannehill and
i talked about this the other day and it
brought back memories of the vibe that
was out there early in the season when
the titans had their issues yeah they
galvanized around the idea that everyone
treated them
like villains that everyone was was down
on them was blaming them was accusing
them and other than the steelers being
salty it's not like there's been this
avalanche of criticism of the ravens
there's been a greater understanding
stuff happens right even though it
traces to a strength coach who
reportedly allegedly whatever hid hid
his his symptoms and and wasn't wearing
a mask and you you're that you're the
pinch point for a lot of exposures when
you're the strength coach because guys
are going into the weight room and
you're there uh and so even with that
there hasn't been a lot of finger
wagging at the ravens because i think
we've learned over the course of the
year that this stuff is just gonna
happen so it's gonna be it's gonna be
interesting to see how the last week and
a half affects or doesn't affect the
ravens tonight on the football field and
what they say about it after the fact
yeah as they're inevitably asked what
impact if any the the ongoing delays and
the ongoing outbreaks had on the ravens
perform
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports